uh
yeah thanks don so i'm sivan uh
and this is
what i'm going to do is basically i'm
going to put forward the proposal so
this talk is not going to be technical
i'm not going to tell you anything you
don't know
we're going to propose an activity
propose something basically some kind of
an implementation challenge and
we basically self-assembled into some
sort of an organizing committee for this
and when i say we i mean eric bowman who
is not here bruce hendrickson and john
gilbert who are both here uh and myself
and
uh we came up with this idea basically
because we
realized like all of you have realized
by now that we can solve laplacian
linear systems or diagonally dominant
linear systems really fast
and that fast laplacian solvers
we now understand imply fast solvers for
other important problems max flow some
finite element problems image processing
problems that gary's group has been
working on and the other the problems
that alexander was talking about
yesterday so there these are two
very important
we feel like i think many other people
in this room feel that these are two
separate very important
uh contributions sets of ideas these
fast laplacian solvers and the
appreciation that these fast laplacian
solvers can can be used as building
blocks for other higher level algorithms
higher level applications
and we basically
felt that we want to reap the benefits
of these two sets of ideas
we want
fast applications like max flow solvers
and so on higher level algorithms and
end user applications that are based on
fast laplacian solvers
this might be some sort of a
maybe so we put here laplacian
revolution maybe the the term that uh uh
gary and richard and dianis used is a
paradigm the laplacian paradigm uh the
idea that you can use the fast laplacian
solvers to solve a range of interesting
uh useful problems and
in our minds the
the
50 year old the 50 year analogy
50 year old analogy is the fft it was an
algorithmic idea
that really served as a building block
for lots of other algorithms and really
changed the way people
designed algorithms in this case mostly
for signal processing people started
looking for algorithms and for
for
constructions abstractions that
can be resolved using the f50 so before
the f50 you could do linear things
non-linear things they could be
time-dependent not
time independent but the fft really
framed
signal processing in terms of what you
can do with the fft so
computer science is bigger than that
it's not i mean we're not claiming or we
don't think that you can solve every
problem in computer science or even even
every graph problem with laplacian
solvers but this could be a useful
building block like the fft was 50 years
ago it's it's it's a limited analogy the
f50 is much simpler it was 50 years ago
but still that's the that's the way we
would like to think about this
um
there is a problem with
getting you know
materializing this revolution and the
the problem is that uh
these
fast
laplacian solvers are fast
mostly in theory so there is now a large
set of ideas
that can be used to construct fast
laplacian solvers
some of these ideas have been converted
into code i think basically the only one
is the code by by the group by gary uh
richard and uh
and janice uh but there are
there are lots of other ideas but
lorenzo there are lots of other ideas
that are still
mostly
paper algorithms there are algorithms
that show up in papers so uh and so this
is so that's why we can't really
reap those benefits right now because
it's not clear that you can now
that you can implement now a fast uh max
flow algorithm even if you use the
laplacian solver as a building block is
a black box because there aren't that
many
really fast uh laplacian soldiers or
plastic servers that have been
demonstrated
uh realistically to be really fast
and
what we are aiming with this effort is
to achieve impact to to to and to
achieve impact you need innovative
algorithms we clearly have lots of
innovative uh
ideas in this in this area you need
theory to explain them i mean in siemens
i don't have to to talk about theory
clearly we have
very complete detailed theories to
explain how these ideas work together
and we need fast implementations and
that part is
lacking not completely missing but
really lacking and the the key idea
is that we want to try
to
to do a community effort to transform
ideas into technology i mean what what
really uh people are after is technology
things that actually do something
compute something and what we have now
falls
somewhat short of that we have ideas we
don't have technology
so what we what we thought is that so we
were basically uh eric and i were
inducted to three weeks ago and we were
thinking about
what it would take to actually do this
transformation from ideas
to technology and the idea we came up
with is an idea to do some sort of a
competitive effort or
we're not focused on the competition
we're focused on the on the impact or
making the impact but we thought that a
competition or a challenge structure
would work well and the idea is that we
want to set up some sort of a
competition where the competition
motivates people to
implement develop and study fast solvers
fast software solvers in in software
software for implementing fast solvers
and the software will generate impact
that right now is latent not is is
potentially possible but not occurring
right now uh and the idea is to try to
motivate
to inspire people to participate and to
also i think an important part of it is
to give
incentives for people to do this work i
think part of the thing that was missing
was incentive i think we can discuss
this later i think this is an important
part i mean when when the the three of
us discussed this uh yesterday
we found that the most
uh the weakest link in this proposal in
this idea is to find a way to motivate
to motivate everybody to to pull
together and to and to do this uh
and and it's it's easy for lots of us to
say
why
this is a really cool idea really a good
idea but
i don't for each one of us doesn't make
sense okay it's a good idea but it
doesn't make sense for me so we're
the the the discussion of whether there
is enough incentive or not enough
incentives really should be we think
should be a key point in this discussion
uh
so that people participate and implement
and this is just the buzzword but uh we
actually we started with the better
buzzword the laplacian olympics but we
we eric and i thought that we would get
sued for trademark violation so we
switched to something that does that's
not trademarked uh but again just a word
i mean maybe we should change this to
an implementation challenge i mean this
is more unique the implementation
challenges there have been several so we
we try to be unique
uh okay so let me talk a little bit
about the the structure uh it's a
proposal we are doing this in order to
get feedback from potential participants
to try to see how to structure this and
like i said how to give incentives that
work for people uh in terms of
participation
uh so the basic structure is i think
kind of different than the dimx
challenges if people are familiar with
them uh and this the overall structure
is that uh
there would be teams you guys and there
is an organizing committee we some
people might might be on both sides but
uh
the
there are teams that implement solvers
and the organizing committee measures
the performance so you can also
obviously you need to measure in order
to optimize to know where you where you
stand but the idea is that there is some
sort of official measurements official
timings uh that the organizing committee
does and we want to do this
for fairness for completeness and for
ease of comparison so we want
eventually to come up with
with data that says that this solver is
fast on these problems and that solver
is fast on those problems so that we can
see people can see where things need to
be improved where there are
opportunities where they're uh black
holes and so on uh obviously you can
also measure
uh and i'll talk about publication you
can measure your data as your data you
can publish your data
uh
uh and
there are specific cases where it's easy
to
to see where
teams would need to measure basically
the amount of measurements that we can
do without exploding the the
without explosion of different
measurements is limited so if you have a
solver that's particularly good at
specific tasks for example low accuracy
it's very fast when you require lower
accuracy we might not test this you can
test this and show that
that
that it's
you do well on particular cases but
basically
you implement we measure
and we try to measure this on one
platform so everybody is on a level
playing field just to back up what he
said yes
will you have public materials so just
to tell you the typical way
say in structural uh determining the
structure of a protein or whatever
typically what you do is as the
governing organization have
puts uploads a very large database of
example problems
and then the actual competitions
are essentially in real time where you
put up more
you know
one or a few
further problems further challenges so
you can't really tune your system yes
guys
and then you compete under those
conditions yes we plan to do something
very close to what you what you
i'll keep going and i'll address the
presentation we'll address both of those
issues
to make this one
one way to give people incentive is to
have in a sporting event is to have lots
of events so that many people can come
out with medals so we are going to have
many different events so
you can er and and the key is both to
cover different applications different
application different application
scenarios and so on but also to give
people opportunity to write codes that
are good at something but not
necessarily at everything okay
uh so they're uh oops
so in terms of the
the problems we're going to have
sort of traditional structurally
structural analysis type
problems 2d 3d meshes
networks maybe scale-free graphs
if we get contributions of
matrices or generators for image
laplacians that come from image
processing would be able to include
those
uh ill-conditioned expander expander
graphs laplacians of
ill-conditioned laplacians of expanders
uh
we're going to test both laplacians and
diagonally dominant matrices unless so
we get to some conclusion
just
i'll
i'll explain
uh and
very importantly
uh will include
all reasonable community contributions
so if you think that you have a solver
that's particularly good at something
you can contribute a matrix generator or
a set of matrices from that application
so that you can do well on this and
everybody else will not do well but
these are these are will be put
out as part of the benchmark set for
everybody to tune their codes on or to
tune their algorithms on so all the all
the testing is going to be using
publicly available
matrix generators mostly and sometimes
instances
uh ill condition so
some so you can see that some of them
some of these are motivated by actual
applications or at least things that are
conceivable applications for fast
laplacians
these four examples are are
examples
are these are matrices that we want to
include in order to try to help
differentiate different solvers so what
what we mean by ill condition expanders
is we generate graph expanders random
expanders and then we'll wait the edges
to make the laplacian highly conditioned
okay and that's that
uh we feel that
we feel that that family of matrices
will make
a large
number of existing solvers look really
bad and will
let the
universal
linear almost linear time bound
algorithms
show their strength okay so so what the
what i mean i i'll
say a little more about different
solvers later but you can imagine that
on you know 2d meshes or even 3d meshes
people have optimized solvers that are
that may not have the kind of universal
theoretical bounds but they've optimized
them for 60 years and they're solvers
that run really really fast
so we want so and other like i said the
community you guys everybody is welcome
to
include families of matrices to
contribute families of matrices that
will help distinguish help
you know
make your solver shine basically
um
uh
we will test serial codes we'll test
parallel codes both shared memory
parallel codes and if there are
contributions that are distributed
memory parallel codes we'll test these
you'll see in a minute that there are
existing distributed memory and shared
memory parallel codes that we can test
they're not they're not specialized to
laplacians they apply to all symmetric
positive definite matrices but we plan
to include them
uh and in terms of the what's important
they were people were asking me
yesterday about you know the metric the
matrix is going to be
stopwatch time time real time uh we're
going to measure time uh and for every
event they're going to be two
winners one for the fastest absolute
time
so you want to use a large parallel
machine or you want to use a large
fraction or all of our parallel machine
you can do that
but also in terms of efficiency so
another kind of metric for success is
the number of cores times time
total computer time that you've wasted
solving that particular linear system
and it's likely that to win here you
need a serial code i mean it's easier
easiest to do this to to make it most
efficient using a sequential code what
about many problems that are solved
approximately
should you look at the
arrow
um
we
that's a it's up for discussion our
current thoughts uh in order to you know
they are that in order to have a playing
level field we're going to require high
accuracy of all the solvers
so if somebody has a
low accuracy low accuracy solver to
compete they will have to boost the
accuracy using an iterative scheme
yes we'll require
uh residuals that are close to machine
epsilon realistically achievable but
close to machine epsilon uh
it's
um okay uh
our intent is there to we will try to to
to have most of the events
be played on
made matrix generators that generate
random instance instances of families of
matrices like 2d meshes we'll you know
draw points in the plane we'll run a you
know triangulation algorithm voronoi or
triangle or something uh
and choose weights but
the idea is that the instances will be
random drawn from a matrix generator
that you will have access to everybody
will be in the competition everybody
solves this exactly the same problem but
the problem so the problems are
identical but they're random uh the
problem sizes will also be random so
it'll be sort of exponentially growing
to see how solvers do
uh asymptotically but their exact sizes
will also be random uh
it's possible that there are some
applications for which we'll have good
specific instances but not
really reliable generators for instances
like this if you think about web graphs
or social network graphs it's uh
people claim that they have generators
for this but it's there is the debate
whether the generators really generate
that that uh that are like web graphs
and so
and so on
um
uh these are
i mean we're like i said this is the
proposal so the accuracy is one issue or
is the size of the residual to stop it
is or to to requires one issue the other
issue is whether to do you know one sold
multiple right-hand sides or uh whether
you you really rep generate whether the
solver generates a a representation of
the inverse that can be applied
relatively quickly to additional
right-hand sides or whether it's a
one-shot algorithm and you have to pay
the entire price again if you solve
another linear system um these are
questions we haven't resolved yet and
it'll be interesting to hear what people
think is
useful
okay
so that's in terms of the overall
structure now we'll talk a little bit
about the teams and afterwards we'll
talk about the
the
timeline the structure of the of
participation how to participate but
before we talk about how to participate
i'll talk a little bit about the teams
uh
so
something is my some teams might be
organic teams or maybe i should start by
saying that we in the initial
discussions we felt that the right way
to participate in this or the most
productive effective way to participate
in this is through teams not through
individual effort i mean we
you're welcome to participate
individually but it's going to be easier
to participate as as part of a team some
some teams are organic people already
know you know
gary and janis and richard and maybe
other students i mean that's that's an
organic team people know already know
each other they already work together
that's great i mean if you can do that
that's great
if you can do that uh like i said it's
going to be helpful uh to team up
uh and we feel that in order to do well
you probably need teams that have both
the theoreticians and strong high
performance computing experts uh we
don't feel
that
this challenge
is
uh
is doable or doable in a useful way by
giving a a stack of papers to an
undergrad and say okay why don't you
implement this it's the the algorithmic
engineering choices i mean if you look
at some of those papers they have
parameters how do you tune the
parameters what's the impact of the
parameters if the parameters even you
know three different parameters you're
in three-dimensional space how do you
find the point that generates a good
algorithm and if you just give them this
to people with even
you know
full professors who are doing high
performance computing their entire
careers they might they they will not be
able to tune those algorithmic
parameters they might be able to do
other things well and so on so i think
it should be
view the challenge should be really
viewed as a research challenge both in
terms of
not inventing new algorithms for
laplacians but in terms of algorithmic
engineering for laplacian solvers and in
terms of high performance computing
getting those codes to run fast so when
you said that you know you're going to
allow people to run parallel ones have
you considered having a separate
competition for something like a gpu
i think i thought about this and right
now my take on this is the gpus is the
kind of thing that you measure on your
own so it's okay to say
uh you enter a code if your code can use
gpus in the official runs it will not
use gpus you can do your own runs we can
help you do runs or maybe on the same
machine with gpus but it's going to be
sort of a
a sideshow okay circus show separate
from the main
sporting event yes
because the hybrid differences are too
much between different gpus or no most
could be mostly because like i said we
want to keep this manageable so people
can ca so we can compare i mean
what you what you're suggesting is that
is great i mean if people can explore
gpus that's fantastic but the likelihood
that multiple teams will be able to use
gp to exploit gpus is not so high and
then
we are not after measuring one code we
are after
a deeper understanding that comes from
looking at multiple
implementations or at least multiple
implementations of multiple algorithms
okay uh there are many things like that
that you can come up with gpus uh like
low precision there are many kind of
things that you can that your solver can
excel in but it's hard to
uh compare across the board
yeah i just want to elaborate on a point
you made earlier that make sure it was
very clearly the value in this certainly
from my view
is not
you know the competition the line on
your resume or whatever value is moving
the community forward in constructive
ways
that
i hopefully will get some nice software
out of this that will be useful to to
you know
to propagating theoretical ideas into
more applied communities
maybe there'll be some new
collaborations that will be that will
arise again
probably most importantly though i think
we collectively will gain greater
understanding about which algorithmic
ideas are effective in practice and
which aren't and that's the real value
here this is just a context to kind of
make it more fun to
to move us forward in those dimensions
yes completely
okay um
i mean this audience is mostly
theoreticians uh you you may know hpc
experts that you can recruit for your
team uh
if you don't we can help uh doing some
matchmaking uh
i think the four of us know people on
both sides both theoreticians and hpc
experts uh
if you want to compete but you feel you
need more talent more expertise we can
try to
sort of suggest people uh
okay uh there's also going to be uh
archaeological relics competing this
again against you
uh and the idea here is that there are
there is a lot of software that can
already solve laplacian linear systems
all of that software as far as we know
can also solve
uh symmetric uh symmetric positive
definite spiral symmetric positive
definite matrices that are not
laplacians but they can still do pretty
well at least on up to some
asymptotic size of n
uh
these include let me this includes
sparse direct solvers there are lots of
them out there uh algebraic multigrade
solvers that are sort of they're not
specialized in laplacians but they're
specialized to problems that are sort of
look like laplacians uh all kinds of uh
conventional preconditioning ideas for
conjugate gradients like incomplete
koleski uh sparse approximate inverses
uh it's possible that some of the
authors of those
software packages will enter the
competition it's also possible that they
will not enter the competition and if
that happens we will
just run their software we will download
those packages and we will run them uh
and the the intent here is to provide a
quantitative context for the performance
of graph
based linear solvers uh and they when i
say the intent the
the bar that we want everybody to to
cross
is
the bar of being able to publish
uh
your so the results of your solver
in the you know
high performance computing numerical
linear algebra literature and without
those comparisons our experience says
you cannot publish anything in that
literature so our intent is to
uh again in terms of advancing things
forward is to show
everybody outside this room that these
solvers are not only fast asymptotically
they're actually faster than
established baselines so and people need
baselines in order to make comparisons
and we'll include the baselines whether
their developers or their uh
whether the developers enter the
competition or not uh there might be
others that we don't if people want to
suggest other solvers that that can be
applied we'll be able to to include them
but we
these are the mains ones these are the
main ones we had in mind
okay in terms of the timeline and the
structure
the idea is that we start this after we
lay out the rules this is just a
proposal is the team
uh people team up uh forms
some sort of team structures and start
implementing or designing the
implementations while we the organizing
committee prepare and release the matrix
generators hopefully at least initial
releases should happen fairly quickly so
that people can code
and test the codes on the matrix
generators
uh you test and optimize and then maybe
four months into this uh
we do a qualifying run or six months
into this we do a qualifying run in the
qualifying run we you submit codes we
test the codes we we time the codes we
collect the results we anonymize the
results and you send we send them back
to you
we tell each team
which anonymous team is their team so
that they can see how their code
performed relative to other codes but uh
you know you're not if your code is slow
you you don't get embarrassed nobody
knows it's you i mean this anonymity in
a small group is sort of shaky but at
least the intent is these are no public
results we're not going to publish those
results these are
uh experimental
setups also these qualifying runs will
help us get the bugs out of the
uh the system that runs the software
that runs the different solvers and so
on negotiate how it should be run and so
on then you get time to optimize again
and then we do the competition and then
there are two
uh uh
further two very important phases
the first one is everybody meets uh
mostly to learn from each other but also
to have a some sort of a award ceremony
but really
to we intend to do a workshop in which
uh people will present what they've done
so that we can learn from each other and
exactly learn which kind of ideas are
useful which kind of ideas have been
tested by the teams and discarded
because they couldn't make them work and
so on so this is a very important uh
idea that we took from the dymax
implementation challenges and we
published the results so
uh which again follow follows this is a
a way of again making those
uh lessons formal and publicizing them
beyond the group that uh participated in
the in the effort
uh how we do this where we do this i
mean i looked for the most appropriate
place in the world that's real applause
in the laughing quarter in paris
but it i i think it lacks the the
facilities to do this but i mean if it
didn't lack that would be a nice place
to do this laplacian competition
uh
so
i mean most of it is going to be online
uh but like i said we're going to have a
workshop and publish a volume of papers
uh on the competition and on the solvers
and we need to find venues for both of
them for the workshop and for publishing
this volume uh
in terms of the publication i i think
again learning you know copying the the
structure of the dymax implementation
challenge there is a paper that
describes a write-up that describes the
structure of the competition the the
test matrices and also all the results i
mean who ranked where or graphs tables
of results so that people can study them
and and figure out uh what's going on
which solver did well and what problems
and every team publishes a paper that
describes the implementation and
explaining the results so your paper for
example can refer to the graphs or the
tables in the in the in the main paper
or you can copy them and so on so the
idea is you say there is an anomaly in
my running time it ran really slow on
some problem sizes and you try to
explain why that happens that's typical
of experimental papers
uh
what needs to be done in experimental
papers
the
intent
is to
um
is to try to collect those papers in one
volume so that people can refer to them
people can study them and have one place
to go when they want to know what makes
a laplacian solver go fast
uh that means
that the
that
we have to be careful about the
quality we demand so one possibility is
to do a special issue in a journal or
something like this but that puts the
bar really high and if you have papers
you know solvers that are really good
and ideas that are really interesting
but the paper that's really shaky
it won't get into acm toms for example i
think we should still include it
included rather than excluded
exclude it
so they put some constraints on where we
publish
but that's up for discussion
uh in terms of the venues like
the imax is an obvious
venue
day rain implementation challenges we
can try to talk to them to see whether
they want to make this the next
implementation challenge uh
they
uh
they hold workshops uh and they have a
series of volumes
on different different proceedings of
con of workshops i think these include
the uh
challenge the challenges uh
we are here at siemens it would be great
to do this as a follow-up at simon's i
think in terms of the at least the
physical venue i think
i i i
i think many people would prefer not to
go to dynamics in new jersey let me okay
so but uh
but these are two two options dagshul is
also an option i think they would be
receptive to this idea and like i said
in terms of the publication dimax has as
a proceedings uh
volumes of proceedings of workshops
especially issue in the journal is more
complicated but it's doable i think
uh and your input is really crucial in
this uh this thing
uh and like i said the main
the main idea the main
the most important thing is for you to
participate if you come out of this
one-hour session and feel that this is a
great idea and your your bystanders your
your the audience that's not going to
fly we really need you to participate uh
that's it
okay maybe i'll switch to john to lead
it
oh the one comment goes
so the plus in paradigm really has two
components right here's the numeric and
there's a graph
so i could imagine that
you know people with skills in one or
the other and you can imagine that
it's enough work just to have a good
graph theoretic component a good
spanning tree algorithm or something
and that that would be an important part
of the competition
as well as the numerix because to the
most part these are two separate things
that have to go
not
together
right depends on the algorithm right but
i mean it needs to be completely
legitimate to say for each of these
generators have people run you know test
out people's low stretch spanning tree
implementations
of course now you suddenly have two
parameters the running time of it and
the quality of the tree
and then we also know from you know the
stretch of the tree is not doesn't
exactly dictate the running time of the
algorithm but
it could be completely that someone has
code that can just take this closer
spanning tree as a black box and you can
combine it with someone else's list or
spanning tree black box and you get
something much better
yeah or at least have a place where
these two pieces of code are right you
know
yes
okay there are two two separate issues
here one is i think
i think we
the organizing committee feels that
we're at the point you know 10 years
after your
your paper and two years after uh the
cosmos paper uh where you know the proof
of the pudding is in the eating so
we want to see the whole package running
together so that's that's one thing so
you're right about the different pieces
that need to go into the solver but i
think we are at the point where we want
to see
complete solvers rather than to do a
challenge on
components like the lows like the low
stress spending tree the time for that
has passed we are past that uh
in terms of how people
i
i completely agree it takes
expertise in numerics in high
performance computing and in graph
algorithms and people we need that's why
i said teams people we knew we need to
put the pieces together
i don't think we are going to have any
constraints on
where people get the pieces from as long
as they're
you know open about this so if you want
to contrib if janice wants to contribute
a low speed low stress stretch spanning
tree implementation put it on google
code and other people want to use it
that's fine if you don't want to put
your your yours because you have a
competitive spirit that you want to win
that's also fine
uh
i mean my idea was that there are people
that only do
the graph algorithm side it'd be nice to
suck them in and one way is to sort of
include experiments that included just
the graft here and there are other
people that do just the numeric side
right for their expertise you can
imagine that it'd be nice to suck them
in
and whether they have to marry to some
other group or not yeah i i completely
agree it would be great to suck those
people in at least my take but this is
open for discussion my take is that you
suck them in into teams that put the
whole package together but rather than
have a separate event for them to
compete in or something like this that
but that's that's my opinion other
people are entitled to other opinions
maybe we'll switch with you